all form is the easiest way to customize
your own premium sofa i have two all
form sofas at home love them both go
customize your sofa shipping is fast and
free and you'll get 20 off when you go
to all form dot com slash pacman
one of the things that is important to
prevent because once the cat is out of
the bag it's very difficult to get it
back in
is the rewriting of history anytime that
we can and when it comes to the last
couple of years the pandemic the trump
administration etc
we've been covering it all closely with
you with no interruption and so it gives
us sort of this perspective where we can
remember what things were like last year
or two years ago
when the right tries to rewrite history
for political advantage or whatever the
case may be now this is a politically
biased show in the sense that this might
come as a shock to some of you which is
a problem but this is not a news
reporting show this is a news commentary
and analysis show i'm on the left i'm a
progressive that's my perspective
but one of the things that i always try
to do
or try not to do depending on your
perspective is
i don't want to toss the political
football back and forth
on issues that are not really worthy of
that and you know that on debt and
deficit i don't play into the debt and
deficit games that both republicans and
democrats play but republicans play it
more for sure because they're the ones
who claim to be the party of uh fiscal
responsibility as they define it uh on
gas prices for example i've told you
guys when it was bush that was president
when it was obama when it was trump now
under joe biden the american president
has very little influence over gas
prices so i don't use gas prices as
something to praise
or
beat down
a president i these games are boring to
me we're beyond them and now the issue
of supply chain and shortages is taking
exactly the same tone and color
um it's joe biden's fault if as the
other day when i went to the grocery
store i couldn't get my granny smith
apples and i tweeted about it and got
into a funny exchange with sam cedar
about it but i'm not blaming joe biden
for that much like i didn't blame donald
trump for the shortage as we saw earlier
in the pandemic but the right wants to
play the games and tom not only
is the right now blaming joe biden for
everything that's going on and saying
well we have shortages because secretary
of transportation pete but edge edge was
on paternity leave
it even led to sort of homophobic stuff
about oh he's learning to breastfeed and
stuff like this
and now
republican senator tom cotton went on
laura ingram's show last night and said
we didn't have shortages under donald
trump during the first year of the
pandemic what
this is beyond parody take a listen to
this
er in the morning you know we've had
this pandemic for two years laura i
don't remember inflation or supply chain
shortages or labor shortages that we've
seen this year in the first year of the
pandemic what changed joe biden and the
democrats took power in january can you
imagine
can you imagine so
labor shortages well that's very very
silly
during
the vast majority of trump's
uh
presidency during the pandemic things
were shut down there were too many
workers in the sense that a ton of
businesses were closed
um entertainment venues movie theaters
sporting events
many restaurants when it came to
in-house dining rather than just takeout
the situation was completely different
that's why there weren't so-called labor
shortages under trump now whether they
are even really shortages now i think
that that's actually the wrong term for
them but that's very silly but he's
saying there weren't supply chain issues
do you guys remember toilet paper under
donald trump you couldn't find toilet
paper
when it came back in stock there were
limits no one package per person you
can't get two packages of toilet paper
under trump was i blaming trump for that
of course not it had nothing to do with
trump there were no n95 masks available
there were no 95 masks available people
were desperate to get those surgical
masks you couldn't get hand sanitizer
couldn't find sanitizing wipes on amazon
your local cvs couldn't find it the
lysol and other sprays i wanted to get
rubbing alcohol sold out everywhere i
ended up ordering a two pack from like
target online or something like that
there were no canned foods you'd go to
the grocery store not only was the
grocery store
packed
with lines waiting outside you couldn't
find canned soup you couldn't find black
beans you couldn't find pinto beans you
couldn't find kidney beans you couldn't
find cannellini beans you couldn't find
refried beans you couldn't find spicy
refried beans you couldn't find fava
beans
okay i could go on i'm big on beans as
you can tell
the dry pasta section
empty no spaghetti no ziti no penne no
gnocchi no pepper deli no rotini
linguine angel hair cavatapi tagliatelli
fusilli macaroni farfale conchiglier
you couldn't find lasagna noodles guys
lasagna noodles i was trying to make
lasagna couldn't find them
um costco was limiting how much meat you
could buy
meat was being rationed folks whole
foods said you only one of each kind of
frozen fruit or vegetable i wanted two
packages of frozen mango i was only
allowed to buy one
there was no flour and sugar people were
baking like crazy due to boredom
couldn't uh ammunition was sold out
everywhere remember that and tom cotton
doesn't remember anything like this
before this year
under joe biden
what
but the important thing is
no one was blaming trump for that back
then even people on the left weren't
saying it's trump's fault that there's
no pit toilet paper because it would be
idiotic just like the other day at the
grocery store i wanted my beloved granny
smith apples and they were sold out
thanksgiving probably had something to
do with it the green apple very very
strong for apple pie
let's put that aside it's not just joe
biden's fault
if anything it's thanksgiving's fall
okay
these guys have to give it up i mean it
we it's on us not to allow them to get
away with this it was not trump's fault
but there were shortages under trump and
it is not joe biden's fault that now you
know i wanted to get quiche crusts the
other day and they were sold out i'm not
blaming pete buddha judge's uh premature
twins that he has adopted that it's just
it just has nothing to do with that it's
very silly let's not allow them to
rewrite history
in addition by the way
as we get into this next story to not
allowing them to rewrite the history of
the pandemic and we're actually going to
speak to nicholas christakis about this
very very important topic
um
we also need to do something
to say guys the trivialization of the
holocaust and the comparisons between
saying you should get a vaccine or get a
get a test every week or if your fox
news get a test every day comparing that
to nazis killing jews it's time for it
to stop and we're going to have a clip
today that is going to perfectly
illuminate for you
why dr anthony fauci needs security why
does a doctor need a security team
partially it's because of what i'm about
to play for you this is a clip of lara
logan who has gone completely off the
deep end dangerously so
likening dr anthony fauci to the nazi
doctor joseph mengele
of auschwitz concentration camp fame
okay
let's just listen to the clip i mean
there's no i don't think we need any
further introduction it's that compare
very much to seasonal flu and so in that
moment what you see on dr fauci this is
what people say to me that he doesn't
represent science to them he represents
joseph mengele dr joseph
the doc the nazi doctor who did
experiments on jews during the second
world war and in the concentration camps
and i am talking about people all across
the world are saying this because yeah
everybody's saying it dr fauci people
you if you go to new zealand new
zealanders are going you know over in
the u.s that dr fauci he's like joseph
mengele what the hell is she talking
about this is why one of the nation's
top doctors
an infectious disease doctor during a
pandemic you've got a pandemic
you've got an infectious disease doctor
he needs security why does he need
security because of stuff like this now
for those of you who don't know much
about joseph mengele
he was known as the angel of death
he would perform
experiments many of which resulted in
death on prisoners at the auschwitz
concentration camp during the holocaust
mengele was a member of the group of
doctors who would choose who gets killed
in the gas chambers
he was one of the doctors who
administered the gas
and lara logan says all over the world
people are saying
people that dr fauci is like joseph
mengele now i think
it it it's i should mention
and this is kind of you know it might
this might sound like a non-sequitur a
lot of people wrote to me after i played
this clip on yesterday's live stream
and said david you know you got to be
careful with lara logan um because she
she was beaten and sexually assaulted
when she was covering the egyptian
revolution in 2011.
now that's absolutely horrifying it is
it is a tragedy
and it is unimaginable what happened to
lara logan and if
her now being
off the deep end
relates to that trauma that's also
absolutely terrible
still
saying that fauci is like joseph mengele
only worsens the disastrous situation
that we find ourselves in today
um
lara logan has been a purveyor of
disinformation recently
she has continually fallen for antifa
hoaxes back in may
she tweeted out a picture of a document
that she said was the antifa battle plan
which includes that antifa has
infiltrated law enforcement and all it
was a total hoax she signal boosted it
um lara logan then posted a picture of a
tweet
supposedly coming from an antifa group
saying we're going to go and terrorize
white neighborhoods it was fake it was
from a white nationalist group she just
constantly falling for this stuff i
could go on
this is not good and so whatever lara
logan is going through personally
it's a tragedy
i feel terribly about it it's it's
unimaginable horror that she suffered in
2011 covering the egyptian revolution
and what she's doing publicly in 2021
almost 2022 in the media sphere
is completely deplorable and she must be
stopped
at some point someone has to say this
isn't responsible and she must be
stopped let me know your thoughts i do
want to remind everybody on december
14th it's almost december on december
14th we will be doing our final david
pakman show viewer town hall of the year
this is where we open the phone lines
and we just take call after call after
call people can call in it is going to
be streaming online only
on the pacman live youtube channel this
is our second channel you find it at
youtube.com pacmanlive
it's free to watch and it's free to call
in okay december 14th 6 pm eastern if
you want
the priority access to speaking to me on
that day get a membership on our website
members do get priority on the town
halls you can sign up at joinpacman.com
one of our sponsors is all form hands
down the easiest way to custom build
your own sofa you choose the premium
fabric you want you choose the sofa size
shape color even the color of the legs
you can customize every aspect of your
new sofa to make sure it's the perfect
fit for your home i got my first
all-form sofa a year ago i just got a
second one which is really exciting
these really are the sofas i would have
bought for my home even if all form was
not a sponsor you really can't beat the
quality the modern minimal design the
sofas are spill stain and scratch proof
you can buy one piece and start with
that and then buy more seats and
accessories to add on later shipping is
fast and free you get a hundred days to
decide if you want to keep the sofa it
comes with a forever warranty and you'll
get twenty percent off when you go to
all form dot com slash pacman the link
is right underneath this video
something that the american right wing
loves doing is blaming the left for the
problems that the right wing has
actually created
this happens i mentioned this earlier
with debt and deficit you'll have a
republican president come in blow up the
deficit accelerating the increase in the
national debt and then on day two of the
next democratic president's
administration say look at this national
debt which we accelerated the growth of
dramatically during our last time
controlling the white house that's one
example
but right now the most prominent example
that i can think of the right saying to
the left you aren't solving fast enough
a problem we created
is on vaccination you simultaneously
have the most anti-vaccine group in the
united states being trump supporting
trump voters followed by republican
voters
and at the same time
you increasingly have the story being
told by that very same right wing
including right wing media
that joe biden's failing because not
that many people have gotten vaccinated
because that very same right-wing media
apparatus has been attacking the
vaccines and i'm going to go to a clip
for you now it is unbelievable that this
is what they are saying
john scott fox news anchor and his guest
hugo gurdon who's the editor-in-chief
for the right-wing publication
washington examiner they did a segment
yesterday attacking joe biden
because not enough of the united states
has gotten vaccinated
completely ignoring the reality
that for months and months and months
fox news has been running segments
critical of the vaccines tucker carlson
saying
we believe maybe thousands tens of
thousands of people could have died from
the vaccine was it that i think maybe on
tucker it was thousands not tens of
thousands others have said tens of
thousands or even hundreds of thousands
laura ingram has been doing it and on
and on and on
no awareness or at least pretending not
to be aware of that fact take a look at
this and yet
this year we have lost more people in
this country to covid
than we did during the the first year of
the
pandemic when donald trump was president
and and now we have the vaccines
exactly so exactly so the the pandemic
exploded in march of 2020 which was 10
months before donald trump was out of
office
president biden by coincidence now has
been in office for 10 months more people
have died under president biden than
under president trump and biden
inherited the vacci the vaccines uh you
know he he he came into office promising
that he was going to get his arms around
this in a way that the previous
administration had not
but his uh but you know vaccination rate
is only 58 here considerably lower than
in other places really and why is that
exact tell us why is the rate so low
what group is keeping that rate so low
so he hasn't got his arms around it and
as i say what this is is just a way of
looking like he's doing something
meaningful but in fact not not managing
this thing very well at all
joe biden has only gotten us to 58 now
it's actually 59
vaccination
why might that be well it's partially
because of fox news itself and as media
matters has catalogued fox has
undermined the vaccination campaign
relentlessly running at least one claim
undermining vaccines nearly every day in
a six-month period
meanwhile fox has implemented its own
even more stringent health policy
remember they require daily testing of
the unvaccinated rather than weekly
testing and they continue to attack
attack attack the vaccines and now they
have the audacity to say
why aren't more people vaccinated here
it's like saying
why aren't other people
quickly putting out the fires that we're
setting and you say that as you are
setting more and more and more fires
this is the organization partially
responsible for not enough vaccination
in the united states and it's this dance
that they're doing between
the vaccines maybe killing people
getting vaccinated should be a choice
get not getting vaccinated is is freedom
and blah blah blah
and on the other hand saying listen uh
joe biden's failing because not enough
people have gotten vaccinated biden was
going to get more people vaccinated and
i don't know if this
you could analyze this in a few ways you
could say this is what they've
calculated makes sense for the best
ratings you feed the anti-vaxx stuff at
night and then during the day you say we
recommend vaccines and joe biden hasn't
gotten enough people vaccinated maybe
it's calculated in that way
maybe it's they want to find something
for everyone so for the people who want
to believe fox news is not part of the
problem well you can say look they're
saying joe biden should have gotten more
people vaccinated and at the same time
if you're looking for a it's your
freedom not to get vaccinated then you
tune in to tucker or to laura ingram or
to whatever you want we knew they were
going to do this when they were going
and just allowing all the anti-vaxx
conspiracy theories to be on air
but then now they're also trying to play
both sides of it and they should be held
accountable will they be in any serious
way i don't really know
okay next i want to talk about um
[Music]
oh man i don't even know how to start
this so
last week i interviewed andrew yang a
former democratic presidential candidate
former um new york city mayoral
candidate during that conversation one
of the topics i brought up was
who from the right
do you imagine would want to be part of
your third party movement and do you
welcome
everybody from the right and he answered
the question and then when he said
everybody's welcome i followed up and i
said okay well what about like real
extremists like white supremacists and
he gave me an answer and i believe that
he sort of botched the answer and as a
result this has led to absolute chaos
including
andrew yang tweeting about of course i
don't support white supremacy and this
is a manufactured controversy now it's
not clear from his tweet whether he's
attacking me or people reacting to what
he said to me but i'm going to play the
full section of the interview for
context you will see that i was totally
genuine in my question
it was not an attack it was not a
manufactured controversy it was not a
gotcha it was just me following up to
what his answer was to my first question
so let's take a look at the original
clip from last week's interview who
exactly that currently considers
themselves to be on the right
does andrew yang imagine bringing into
the forward party and to kind of
make it a little more specific you know
we would imagine that there's lots of
progressive democrats more centrist
democrats even some folks who really
consider themselves centrist maybe in
the kind of line of even like a john
mccain who like the idea of some of the
reforms you're talking about and that
all kind of makes sense to me
when i think about people who believe
donald trump won the election
vaccines
the covet vaccine magnetizes you causes
autism whatever the case may be
etc right you know the package of ideas
that i'm talking about one are are those
people that would even conceivably say
this forward party idea that andrew yang
proposes in a coalition with the left
makes sense and number two are these
even people that you want as part of
your coalition
first let me say i want everyone as part
of the coalition you know if you can
vote we can disagree on a lot of things
uh it's all to the good if we agree on
the fact that this duopoly is uh not
working it's designed to turn us against
each other and sink us so that that's
one of the principles of the ford party
is that look i can disagree with you on
a lot of stuff but if we can make common
cause on this then we can go back to
disagreeing when the democracy is
actually set up to succeed when they're
you know
so let me i mean let me ask so even i
mean to to make it really specific
if people on the right say the
republican party is too centrist i'm an
extreme white supremacist or something
like that but i think we need to get you
know we need single transferable vote or
whatever and campaign you you you still
welcome that because you're on the same
page on that one issue
yeah if they're going to help us
transition to a more effective democracy
um like you know i don't need to know
what their stance is on things that i
disagree with people have a sense of
where i'm coming from okay but right now
i believe that there is
an existential threat to the country um
as a result of the greatest design flaw
in the history of the world okay
so
his answer which i don't think was a
great answer
um
created a buzz and a lot of people
saying wow andrew yang welcomes white
supremacy some people taking it out of
context some people just saying wow that
wasn't a really great answer so andrew
yang ultimately took to twitter a few
days after the interview
where he wrote quote
i didn't think this needed stating but
people who hold ideologies such as white
supremacy that are antithetical to grace
and tolerance are not welcome in the
forward party our movement for democracy
reform is fighting to diminish harmful
extremism now remember in the interview
with me he said that it would be fine
that they would be welcome as long as
they're okay with ranked choice voting
that's what he said i didn't trick him
into saying that he followed up with
another tweet
which said quote relatedly this kind of
manufactured controversy is the kind of
thing that's dragging down our public
discourse and distracting us from the
true issues at hand he gave a bad answer
racist is not the path to enlightenment
now i didn't know whether he was
accusing me of manufactured controversy
or others on twitter of manufactured
controversy but in response to this i
tweeted
assuming this tweet is a response to the
question i asked during our interview i
hope it needs no clarification that i
was not attempting to manufacture
controversy and ask the question
completely genuinely after reading the
book now after the interview andrew and
i spoke off air for a bit
and he said your question about white
supremacy it actually got me thinking
and he said he hadn't considered it he
came up with the answer you see him
pause when he answers the question he
didn't say it was unfair or a gotcha or
manufactured controversy we had a
perfectly nice conversation so i hope
and am leaning towards
he was talking about people on twitter
weaponizing his answer now that being
said
i think he just did not answer the
question that well
if i were him the way i would have
answered that question would have been
to say david listen
i've denounced white supremacy
uh many times during the last few years
it's hard to imagine too many white
supremacists wanting to join a movement
led by an asian guy
but i can't control to whom these
principles appeal
and just like any candidate might end up
with anybody supporting them
i can't control that but
am i inviting white supremacist of
course not do i think white supremacist
will even be interested in this movement
of course not that's how i would have
answered the question he answered it a
different way which was to say yeah if
they want rank choice voting then
they're welcome
so
um what is this ultimately really about
for me it's about
who exactly from the right are we
looking to pull in to this forward party
and we had a good conversation about
that
and i don't know that necessarily more
has to be said but i'd be curious to
your reaction to the entire exchange
um some of you have been asking me hey
david sir why haven't you been showing
us
peter ducey's questions during jen
saki's press briefings because he's
still asking those attempted gotcha
questions and he's failing and i'll be
honest with you the reason i haven't
been playing them for you is the the
questions have gotten really boring and
pedantic i'm going to play to kind of go
through this exercise i'm going to play
a couple of them for you today from
yesterday but the back story on this is
that from day one
fox news reporter peter ducey's main
goal in the white house press briefing
room has been
try to use some kind of gotcha question
to either make gensake look bad or joe
biden look bad to then go on fox news
and have everybody give him a good old
atta boy and say you did great and have
the fox news audience titillated um and
and uh excited about the questions that
he's asking and there was one point
where the questions were so off the wall
that they were actually funny
entertaining silly whatever
they're so boring now that i just
haven't been playing them and i'll give
you some examples and you guys tell me
whether you think this is something i
should be covering on the show i
understand i'm covering it now but we
haven't talked about ducey for months
and you're gonna see why because i think
that these are just such boring
questions they don't really deserve our
time let's take a quick look at the
first question from yesterday before joe
biden was president he said that coveted
travel restrictions on foreign countries
were hysterical xenophobia and
fear-mongering so what changed
well i would say first to put it in full
context peter what the president was
critical of was the way that the former
president put out i believe a xenophobic
tweet uh
and how he called what he called the
cocuronavirus
and and who he directed it at the
president has not been critical of
travel restrictions we have put those in
place ourselves we put them in place
ourselves in the spring but no he does
not believe he believes we should uh
follow the advice of health and medical
experts that's exactly what he did and
putting in place these restrictions over
the weekend now i think that the better
topic is and i already broached this
there's a really good topic here okay
this thing about biden saying travel
bans are xenophobic and the counter
being no no no he said the way trump was
talking about the china virus and china
is xenophobic but travel bans themselves
are not it's so boring the real question
is
south africa did a good thing by
sequencing the new omicron variant joe
biden's calling it omnicron but it is
omicron the omicron variant alerting the
world to it
by the time we learned about it
it was
we knew it was already in a handful of
other countries i think it was like
belgium
hong kong netherlands
it's been found in canada okay and then
as a result of learning about this from
south africa
uh a travel ban was placed by a number
european union u.s other on
countries from southern africa including
south africa and other countries down
there and so the real question here is
are we punishing a region of the world
not south africa specifically but some
of those other countries in southern
africa
that are not wealthy countries because
they did the right thing and they told
us what's going on when it's already
spread the cat is already out of the bag
does that really make sense and
everything i'm reading from public
health experts is the travel bans at
this point don't really make sense you
got to keep testing you got to do
whatever else but it's everywhere at
this point it doesn't really make too
much more sense to block travel from
some of those countries than some other
countries that don't have any travel
that that's like a good topic
he wants to go what about joe biden and
saying xenophobia um and then also here
going with a question about joe biden
not wearing a mask in a store he was
shopping in a store and on the glass
outside it said face covering required
and we could see him inside and his face
was uncovered well again peter our
recommendation and advice continues to
be for people to wear uh masks when they
are required in establishments i don't
know what this establishment was the
president obviously follows the health
the advice of his health and medical
team is there concern that when the
president says today please wear your
masking doors in public settings around
other people and he doesn't do that that
it's going to make it harder to get
people to follow him i think you see the
american people and all of you see the
president wearing a mask every time he
comes out to an event so you guys get
the picture i mean listen does it does
it look not great for if biden's saying
you got to wear masks inside
and then he goes into a business and he
doesn't wear a mask like is is that
does that hurt his his argument
it probably does to some degree but the
people that are not wearing masks are
already not wearing masks they're not
going to say oh
biden was photographed without a mask so
in that sense it's another one of these
wastes of a question wanting to create a
sound bite so listen that's why i've not
been covering the ducey questions
because they're boring
they're kind of pointless and they're
very pedantic but if you guys want more
coverage of the ducey questions let me
know and you can let us know we'll be
posting this clip to our instagram at
david pakman show you can let us know
there in the comments
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
it's great to have back on the program
today nicholas christakis sterling
professor of social natural science at
yale university also author of the book
apollo's arrow the profound and enduring
impact of coronavirus on the way we live
now out as of last month in paperback
with a bunch of new material still very
very accurate um great to have you back
on
thank you so much for having me david
it's good to be back on so last time we
spoke uh january of this year it was
very early in the vaccine rollout you
and i spoke a little bit about the
societal impact that the pandemic had
had to to that point maybe to kind of
get us into the conversation today are
you surprised at the degree
of uh partisanship in the adoption of
vaccinations since you and i last spoke
or is it in line with what you expected
no the partisanship
and the sort of ideological way we've
approached many aspects of the
of the pandemic has surprised me a
little bit to be honest i mean i i like
the fact that
we live in a plural democracy you know
we do not live in a monarchy or an
autocracy or in some kind of a society
where everyone has the same opinions
either because they're forced to or
naturally we live in a society with a
tremendous amount of ideological
diversity which i find healthy
regardless of what part of the spectrum
you are on
and one of the other things that's a
feature of our society is that we
resolve our disputes
not by force of arms
but by voting so we we vote that's how
we you know come to express a consensus
and but what's interesting to me so so i
like the fact that we have this
ideological diversity but what perplexes
me is that we have we are increasingly
or at least with in the setting of the
pandemic we seem to be expressing our
ideological diversity
via our response to pandemic and that's
weird in other words if you
believe in a cause or a candidate get a
bumper sticker get a lawn sign i mean
use a conventional means of signaling
your political identity
to signal your political identity by
whether you wear a mask or not or by
whether you get vaccinated or not
strikes me as foolish it is taking
something which should be just
technocratic
and uh
just you know non-ideological and making
it into something that's ideological and
i think that as a nation that has harmed
us tremendously
um
we always had some vaccine hesitancy
typically that originated on the far
left actually prior to this pandemic now
we have a far right group that is uh
it has a lot of vaccine hesitancy
uh we
and the and the people that are vaccine
hesitant are are a heterogeneous mix of
people some have political motivations
others have other sort of
you would say more sensible concerns
like they're worried the vaccines were
developed too swiftly uh or some have
conspiracy ideas which are easy to rebut
you know they're just false i mean they
may they may not listen to you when you
rebut them but they're patently false
there aren't little micro magnetic chips
in the vaccines and so on
uh so
so it's a problem vaccine hesitancy is a
problem the politicization of our
response is a problem and it's a problem
not just for those individuals
but also for our society
when you look at that combined with i
mean i think another issue to to to
choose one other issue to talk about and
then we'll kind of tie them together
another thing that's going on in a lot
of the discussions of what the path
forward is are sometimes kind of
inaccurate assessments of the base
levels of risk prior to the pandemic and
you know in a typical flu season you you
would see
about a hundred people per day die of
the flu over the course of the year now
it's concentrated over flu season so
it's not literally a hundred per day but
you know we're now at a thousand or so
and so we kind of are trying to think
about how do we evaluate the level of
risk that would be acceptable to quote
go back to normal
and everybody has a different metric
that they might be using some people are
saying
the fact that now we need a third dose
and they're talking about fourth doses
that's making me kind of throw in the
towel and say i'm going back to normal
now because otherwise it seems like i
maybe never will other folks are saying
well
until
we really don't need masks i am going to
live life one way and then when the
masks aren't needed i'm going to quote
go back to normal others are looking at
case numbers etc
what is your general assessment of the
metrics by which we should be thinking
about going back to normal and even what
it means to go back to normal at this
point
well i do discuss all this in in in the
book in apollo zero but uh
but let me try to take a stab at that i
think the first thing i would do is just
step back and have a high order
understanding that people need to
understand that our world has changed
there's something new about the world it
was not there two years ago it's a
deadly virus it's it's it's not as bad
as smallpox or bubonic plague or cholera
but it's not like influenza or
chickenpox it kills this virus kills
about one percent of the people that it
infects that's a pretty serious
pathogen that's a that's a serious virus
and that virus was not there before and
now it is there it you can think of it
like sort of radioactive rain that is
you know making every surface toxic or
something
it is it's a new feature of our
environment and i think the idea that we
could just
pretend it's not there
is wrong-headed now
there's also some wisdom in accepting
the new reality that is to say well the
world has changed
that's that sucks
but let's just accept it
and i understand that point of view but
i also think it's important to
understand that we have over 750 000 of
our fellow citizens that have died in
the last year and a half because of this
pandemic and probably as many as a
million will ultimately die and that is
a catastrophic loss of life
you know hundreds of thousands of our
fellow citizens have died
five times as many will be disabled by
this virus that people who survive they
don't have long or short covet they get
over their covet but now their bodies
are are harmed they have they have a
pulmonary fibrosis or renal
insufficiency or or cardiac or
neurologic or psychiatric problems as a
result of the virus so 5 million
americans will have that plus
10 times as many people as die
will be grieving the death of a loved
one that's another 10 million americans
and and so so there are lots and lots of
our fellow citizens who are going to
suffer from this condition and i think
it doesn't serve us well to just you
know whistle by the graveyard and
pretend that nothing is is happening
something is happening and it's not a
trivial thing that's happening and so it
is right for us
to consider
how to cope with it now
we are approaching the end of the
immediate phase of the epidemic
when we reach this herd immunity
threshold sometime in 2022 that our
country will get there
but as the omicron variant has
illustrated
the whole world has to get there because
now new variants are going to come you
see and could could potentially cause
more problems but what you need to think
about it is unless you're a hermit
or you're very lucky
either you will get vaccinated with this
condition or you'll be infected by the
with it those are your choices at some
point yeah
you got to get the vaccine or you're
going to get vaccinated or both uh and
and
getting the disease naturally
unvaccinated you have about a one
percent chance of dying getting
vaccinated you've got a 1 in a million
chance of dying so it
from the vaccine so it is it is a
no-brainer what the rational choice
should be in terms of those those two
alternatives and
wait can you go back to that just for
clarity one in a million chance of dying
from the vaccine okay yes so the the
latest i've seen is you know these these
three cases of myocarditis after the
vaccine that led to death where is one
in a million coming from i've not heard
that i'm saying it's less than one in a
minute oh i'm sorry less than okay yeah
yeah yeah yeah the order one in a
million in other words what we from a
public health point of view we we did we
always tolerate some risk of death from
vaccines right the idea is you give a
vaccine you save 10 000 lives and you
lose one life and uh you know that's a
trade-off that you make uh with any
public policy you know
with how you build your roads or how you
secure the safety of your factories
these are always issues like there's
some downside and there's some upside
and you want the upside to be vastly
higher than the downside which it is
with vaccines so these vaccines these
coronavirus vaccines are exceedingly
safe as vaccines go far surpassing
typical standards
and and if they're far better than
getting the disease naturally which you
know poses a risk of death anyway the
point is that everyone is going to
either get vaccinated or get the disease
and
and and when that happens then we will
have reached this herd immunity
threshold which will be sometime in the
next few months in our society this is
assuming we don't get new worrisome
strains of the virus that can evade the
vaccines or otherwise are more deadly
for example which could muck up the
works of what i'm saying but anyway
so we're going to get to that point soon
and i think that is going to be one
landmark of when we can quote return to
normal now we're not going to
immediately return to normal because
think about it this way it's like a
tsunami washes up ashore
and devastates the countryside
well eventually the water recedes
that's great you know the sea level has
returned to normal
but the countryside is devastated right
there's a huge mess that needs to be
cleaned up and that's a little bit of
what what's going to happen to us you
know when
when we pass into the intermediate phase
of the pandemic after we reach this herd
immunity threshold
we're going to have had millions of
children that miss school millions of
our fellow citizens that are disabled as
we just said tens of millions that are
grieving the loss of loved ones millions
of people who've lost their jobs
millions of businesses that have gone
out of business we were borrowing
trillions of dollars against the future
to kind of
soften the blow right now we have to
repay those debts so all of that is
still going to affect us you know it's
not going to be like a sudden oh we're
just back to normal again so that's
going to take some time as well anyway i
i think i understand people's desire to
return to normal i understand the
fatalism that says well what can you do
the world has changed there's this awful
virus
but i would say that we don't need to
tolerate needless deaths you know just
because a fire is raging
doesn't mean you need to say well when
these fires rage many houses burn down
and you know what can you do anyway no
you're out there with your hose right
you're hosing down your roof and you're
hoping that your house doesn't burn down
and i think those steps are prudent
steps
and steps we should be making with
respect to the pandemic as well
what are you not doing now that you were
doing before the pandemic like how have
you set your level of what you do and
what you don't do
i
i'm not as i i do first of all i'm
triply vaccinated uh and i would
encourage people to get the booster
there is some preliminary evidence that
the booster will also help with the
omicron variant yes as well
and um
uh
although in general vaccine efficacy
will decline it declined when the delta
variant came so roughly speaking the
vaccine was let's say 95 effective
against the original wuhan strain of the
virus maybe 90 we're talking about the
mrna vaccines now 90 effective against
delta so loss of efficacy but still
a 90 effective vaccine is a very
effective vaccine
that means if you
if you get infected with the virus it'll
lower your risk of death by 90 let's say
which is amazing
and probably it'll be lower than that
for omicron with the existing
vaccines that the manufacturers are
racing to produce new customized
versions of the vaccines yeah um and we
should by the way we should welcome that
i don't think you should say oh well
oh look at those pharma companies
they're trying to get me to take more
vaccines well no we're lucky that
they're they can make these vaccines
just like tetanus you know you get a
tetanus shot every 10 years that's a a
prudent thing to do yeah so
so um
uh so i lost my train of thought in
terms of what you're not doing at this
point what i'm not doing so i'm triply
vaccinated which is sensible
i still wear a mask when i go to crowded
indoor environments with strangers
i am seeing friends and family in my
house who i know to be vaccinated with
of course without masks so i am resuming
sort of small scale social interactions
with known individuals
um
and i and i'm
i'm minimizing some other things like i
don't travel as much as i used to for
example i don't um
you know i don't go to i do go to indoor
restaurants but not as much as i used to
you know i'm just sort of um
i still haven't fully
you know resumed my previous level of
social interaction uh from uh prior to
the pandemic unfortunately and i look
forward to being able to honestly i'm
i'm fed up with this i find wearing a
mask really tedious and irritating um
but i think it's a
prudent precaution yeah i know it sounds
like um it sounds like you're you're
basically doing what i'm doing and you
know even with the indoor restaurants i
was talking to my girlfriend the other
day i was saying for me i'm not doing
this because people wear a mask while
they order and walk to the table i'm
just evaluating is it a really crowded
restaurant with tables close together or
not like if it's not i don't really care
about the masks to walk up to order that
seems i don't know
yeah plus you're young and
um it's it's a it's a brief you know
you're only in the restaurant for an
hour i mean these are all the thing
about the life during the time of a
pandemic is that
it's all shades of gray these are all
relative risks there's no life with no
risk yes and so you know you might you
know going to an indoor rock concert
where people are yelling and screaming
for two and a half hours with 20 000
people is different yeah going with your
girlfriend to a hushed tones restaurant
you know for an hour yeah it's different
and it's different if you're 80 and
immunocompromised and if you're 30 and
healthy it's different and so
you know i think
i think if people are prepared to
think that way
and to understand that there are
degrees of risk and if they're also
willing to do their part right the this
is the other thing that's so irritating
to me about the anti-vaxxers
is that to the extent that we all get
vaccinated quickly
then we can all resume normal life more
rapidly right like if we get our
vaccination level up to 85
like the portuguese did for example you
know then we don't then we don't have to
stay six feet apart anymore when we go
to we go to the supermarket and we can
begin to resume more normal life but
yeah
in a way we are
we are shooting ourselves in the foot by
not availing ourselves of this
technology which by the way is one of
the hallmarks of american science and
capitalism i mean we
one of the things that upsets me is that
is that we did not bring our best game
to this fight you know that the chinese
are an authoritarian government and they
have a kind of collectivist culture and
they use their tools to cope with the
virus i would not be happy to live in
china under the constraints that are in
china but those are the strengths the
chinese had and they
you know they are effectively
controlling the epidemic
now we could not have done that in the
united states
but we had
money and science
and we invented vaccines very quickly
why on earth wouldn't we use them
the biggest advocates of the system that
yes that allowed that are now saying i
don't want it yes it's it's odd right
it's like it's like you know
and also it's a little immature like
what do you expect you expect that our
your neighbors will be dying from a
contagious disease you're facing a risk
of death from a contagious disease and
nothing will be asked of you right you
know uh really you know um we're gonna
have to pay more taxes we're gonna have
to run risk of death we're gonna have to
wear masks we're gonna have to get
vaccinated we're gonna have to do a
bunch of inconvenient things because our
world has changed and i think it's
immature to
sort of fantasize that nothing is
different let's pause our conversation
there with nicolas christakis we will
have the full extended interview on our
youtube channel at youtube.com slash the
david pakman show we'll take a quick
break and be right back
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies mugs and
t-shirts you can support the show for as
little as two dollars a month check it
out at patreon.com david pakman show all
right let's look at something very very
interesting um yesterday i played for
you we did kind of like a uh review of
weekend disinformation and propaganda
about vaccines in covid yesterday and
one of the clips i played for you was a
clip of republican congresswoman nancy
mace
um saying on fox news hey you know what
natural immunity is better than getting
vaccinated
so maybe it's a good thing if more
people just get this new omicron variant
and um
that was a clip we played yesterday and
what's fascinating is within hours of
that appearance she was on cnn saying
i'm vaccinated vaccines are great and
everybody should get vaccinated and it
is an incredible trumpian move
of say everything about any issue
so that whoever can find an instance
of you saying the thing that they want
to hear you say uh speaking out of both
sides of her mouth so so let's review
here's her clip on fox news over the
weekend take a listen we played this
yesterday and one of the things that the
cdc has not done and no no policymaker
at the federal level has done so far is
taking into account what natural
immunity does and that may be what we're
seeing in florida today
in some studies that i've read natural
immunity gives you 27 times more
protection against future covet
infection than a vaccination and so we
need to take all of the science into
account and not selectively choosing
what science to follow when we are
making policy decisions and you're
seeing i believe governor desantis is uh
you know seeing the fruit of that labor
today yeah so ron desantis is doing a
great job one of the worst governors
when it came to handling covid natural
immunity gives you 27 times the
protection it doesn't
maybe she meant 27 percent in one case
if you were recently infected versus
having a vaccine tailored to earlier
variants but of course
solving kovid building immunity by
letting everyone get sick is a way to
have millions and millions of people die
right we're we've had hundreds of
thousands die which is crazy but we
would have millions and millions that
horribly irresponsible comment to make
what on earth is she talking about but
then she goes on cnn
and she says something totally different
listen to this i've been a proponent of
vaccinations and and wearing masks when
we need to i run ads encouraging
my district to go and get vaccinated and
when we have these variants and we have
these spikes to take every precaution
from washing our hands to wearing the
n95 or kn 95 mask
wow
wow it this is the trump idea
take every side of an issue
so everyone can find you saying
something you like and she's of course
tailoring it to the audience one message
for cnn viewers and a different message
for fox news viewers it's quite frankly
like two totally different people i mean
it sounds like two different people
she has to tell the base
she doesn't like the vaccines she's
skeptical what about freedom what about
just letting natural immunity give us
protection
but then she has to go to the more
moderate audience on cnn and say i've
been four vaccines from the beginning
i've been for masks wearing n95 going
above and beyond and she can maintain
the kind of plausible deniability that
may suit her by taking
a different position for each group this
is part of the republican assault on
reality
what should we be doing because at the
end of the day we can explain why she's
doing this by saying well look at the
audience on fox and then look at the
audience on cnn but ultimately
these are conflicting statements saying
we should be looking very strongly at
getting natural immunity by getting
people sick and having them recover if
people get vaccinated your chance of
getting sick is lower if you wear a mask
your chance of getting sick is lower so
they they're not you can't do both they
are opposites quite literally there's a
really good quote
uh from the french philosopher jean-paul
sartre who um he
he made this statement about
anti-semites
but if you replace anti-semite with
trump cultist or whatever it applies to
what is going on right now let's look at
the quote so he wrote never believe that
anti-semites will sit never believe that
trump is
are completely unaware of the absurdity
of their replies they know that their
remarks are frivolous open to challenge
but they are amusing themselves for it
is their adversary who is obliged to use
words responsibly
since he believes in words
the anti-semites the trumpists have the
right to play
they even like to play with discourse
for by giving ridiculous reasons they
discredit the seriousness of their
interlocutors
they delight in acting in bad faith
since they seek not to persuade by sound
argument
but to intimidate and to disconcert if
you press them too closely they will
abruptly fall silent loftily indicating
by some phrase that the time for
argument is passed and that's exactly
what they will do they will say
something like well i'm not going to
split hairs with you
uh i'm not well this isn't about point
counterpoint
etc etc beautifully
accurately applies
to what we are seeing right now that was
a phrase and and to be clear
because i know that then other youtube
channels will say look at david pakman
saying trumpists are like anti-semites
i'm not saying trumpists are
anti-semites although some are what i'm
saying is
the mechanism described by jean-paul
sartre there which he talked about with
anti-semites applies today
with how these trump cultists play fast
and loose with what we would call the
truth um i don't want to spend a lot of
time on this next story but i did want
to mention it
um we have a new uh report
which indicates that briefing donald
trump was the most difficult of any
president that the cia has had to brief
now anecdotally remember that we learned
that the
presidential daily briefing under trump
was reduced to one page
half the page
was an image or a chart and then there
were like two or three bullet points and
check this is so funny
business insider reports briefing donald
trump as he prepared to enter the white
house was more difficult than briefing
any other incoming president a book
published by the cia said the
publication getting to know the
president by john helgerson former
intelligence officer charted different
president's interactions with
intelligence agencies in it helgerson
wrote for the intel community
the trump transition was far and away
the most difficult in its historical
experience with briefing new presidents
helgerson's book was published by the
cia for u.s officials the cia says in
the book that its contents are the
authors and do not reflect the position
of the cia okay yeah we understand that
helgerson wrote the only comparable
experience to trump's transition was
that of nixon quote the only and
imperfect analog was the nixon
transition he said after nixon
effectively declined to work with the
intelligence community and instead got
his information through an intermediary
trump was like nixon suspicious and
insecure about the intelligence process
but unlike nixon in the way he reacted
rather than shut the intelligence
community out trump engaged with it but
attacked it publicly
helgerson's new book uh helgerson's book
was first published in 96 it has been
updated with each new president so
imagine expert comes in and explains
something trump interrupts you trump
corrects you trump asserts he knows more
and you were wrong trump will publicly
then attack your institution sometimes
he will even attack individuals from the
intelligence community i was reading
about this and i saw a good comment
written by just just a random commenter
summarizing trump as quote an incurious
anti-intellectual narcissist incapable
or unwilling to learn information
necessary to do the job
so high on himself that he quote knows
more than the generals and only listens
to those who manage to compliment him
enough a tactic several foreign leaders
employed to get him to pay attention for
half a second
a very apt summary
and he might win again tens of millions
of people want the guy back and that's
really what should be scaring us right
now
um i got a very funny voicemail from the
eggman yesterday on the bonus show pat
talked about his thanksgiving break very
exciting visit to the country of
colombia
i talked about a pretty low-key
thanksgiving with half of the people
around me panicking about omicron
and eggman didn't didn't find my stories
interesting take a listen
pat how was your vacation what did
colombians did stuff
dave how's your vacation omicron omicron
omicron virus virus omicron everybody is
scared omicron yeah i have no idea what
you did for the holiday break dave
because all you said was omicron omicron
like 13 times
um
i don't know
uh
i hope you did more than just omicron
shalom brother barely not only shalom
but happy hanukkah eggman we do uh
tonight is the third
is it yeah third night tonight
uh third candle goes on uh on tonight
yeah no i mean i said i i didn't do much
and um there was just a lot of it was it
was
i was around a lot of omicron talk i i
apologize that it does not suit the egg
man but that is what it was
on today's bonus show we will talk about
tulsi gabbard's new declaration that
america is not a racist country as
proven by the ahmad arbory verdict
we will talk about the latest cnn host
chris cuomo accused of using his media
sources to find information about his
brother andrew cuomo's accusers
and a texas father has shot his own
daughter dead
accidentally we might call it
negligently while hunting
while hunting another tragedy with a gun
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show sign up at joinpakman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
all form is the easiest way to customize
your own premium sofa i have two all
form sofas at home love them both go
customize your sofa shipping is fast and
free and you'll get 20 off when you go
to allform.com
pacman